Hank: It’s the beach!
John: A couple of nerds at the beach.
Hank: We’re actually quite far away from
the ocean 'cause there, there’s sharks in
there.
John: Henry’s very nervous about orcas.
He keeps being, like, “Is an orca going
to eat me?” and I’m like “Well not if
you’re eight inches in the water."
Hank: Good morning John.
John: Good morning Hank.
Hank: It’s Friday.
John: Yeah, it is Friday.
Hank: Uh huh, ahh… how are your hotdog legs.
The infernal day star is shining its radiation
down upon us; I can feel it giving me cancer.
John: Light is the visible sign of the invisible
light. That’s T. S. Elliot.
Hank: It’s lovely but it, it doesn’t mean
anything to me.
John: When I ask Henry what light is he always
says in his cute little four year old voice
“It’s the visible sign of the invisible
light." find that very adorable. Question
Friday, the day that we answer real questions
from real Nerdfighters. We took our laptop
down to the beach because that’s how we
roll. Am I on the screen? I’m a little worried
that you’re cropping me…
Hank: You’re there!
John: I’m worried that you’re cropping
me out.
Hank: Yeah, it’s a really wide lens.
John: Alright.
Hank: Melissa wants to know “When is the
Art Assignment going to premiere?”
John: The first episode of the Art Assignment
comes out late February. Subscribe, link in
the dooblydoo.
Hank: She also wants to know “Who the eff
is Hank?”
John: Ohhhh!
Hank: You weren’t prepared for this?!
John: I waah, ahhh, ahh, I’m never ready!
Hank is the second largest ocean on Earth!
Hank: I don’t even know which one that is.
John: That’s this one!
Hank: Oh.
John No, I think this is the Gulf, but whatever.
Hank: If you two were fighting and your only
weapons were the object to your left, how
would you use them and who would win?
John: You have a chair.
Hank: Either that or you. I could just beat
you with you. Why are you hitting yourself?
John: I just have the sand.
Hank: Nah ha! It's a computer!
John: I would sand Hank’s computer because
there is nothing that would upset him more.
He would panic.
Hank: Danny want to know “How come Dave
Green is never in the videos?”
John: Who’s Dave?
Hank: The third unsuccessful brother. Dave
has been made up by a Tumblr.
John: How did this happen and I didn’t even
know about it? Suddenly I have an imaginary
brother.
Hank: Amy wants to know “Why is love so
hard?” (Singing) What is love?
Both: (Singing) Don’t hurt me, no more.
Hank: That was really not even close.
John: People on the beach are looking at us
funny by the way.
Both: (Singing) The people on the beach they
think that we’re crazy. The people on the
beach they think that we’re crazy.
John: It should always be a little bit of
work because it matters.
Hank: Yeah, If you th… Yeah, that’s true.
John: Anyway, there’s all different kinds
of love.
Hank: There’s all different kinds of farts.
John: (laughs) This is a really good YouTube
video. We should, we should do this, we should
do this more often.
Hank: In comments tell me all the different
kinds of farts.
John: No, in comments tell us about Dave Green.
Hank: Just… I need that. No I need that
John. We need that for the rest of video.
John: I know.
Hank: So… So go get some glue. Beautiful.
Wendy wants to know “Which of you has the
worst glasses prescription?”
John: I don’t know. Let’s take a switcheroo
here. Definitely me.
Hank: Yeah, definitely you. Wow!
John: Wait until you’re old.
Hank: I am on acid right now. Well yours is
very sharp but none of the things are lining
up.
John: You know, your left, your left eye is
almost identical to my left eye. Your right
eye is…
Hank: Yeah the right eye.
John: Super weird. Who looks better in the
others glass…?
Hank: Do I look like a naughty professor?
John: Who looks better in the others glasses?
Hank: Is that, is that a thing? Naughty professor?
John: I don’t think so. I think you made
that up. It’s a… What is it? It’s nutty.
A nutty professor. That’s what you were
thinking of.
Hank: Oh, I wanted to ask, uh, if you could
tell me anything about The Fault in Our Stars
trailer.
John: Ahh, umm, grrr, umm, mmm! It will come
out soon in the next few weeks and, um, yes.
I have seen it. I thought it was truly excellent.
I hope other people like it too. I’m very
nervous for everyone to see it but hopefully
soon.
Hank: John, thanks for being on a… question
video with me.
John: Oh no thanks for…
Hank: And taking me here to Florida where
I probably got a sun burn just in the last
twenty minutes.
John: I have sunscreen on.
Hank: I didn’t do that.
John: Best wishes. We need to wrap up this
video.
Hank: I need to go because I’m… I may
actually not survive this. Uh, I’ll see
you on Tuesday.
​(music)
Hank: How’s it going?
John: Oh boy! We got a fish!
Hank: This is a very small ocean you’ve
put me in.
Hank: I don’t think so.
John: So you’re our entertainment?